Canoga Nina Ferran esposa no takey O'Day
Oh Krishna
uh thanks random sponsor lady but it's
actually my job to tell people this
videos wants it improve by in the
restaurant like borign esposa no take yo
Day or Christmas Kay no no you're not
listening to me you're not even
including all the information we need to
include anyway you know like this is a
pretty fun online game based on Naruto
universe that's free to play it's even
officially licensed for God's sakes you
don't know that we need to include all
that pornog on that bottomless ball so
nobody even understands who you are
anymore anyway who doesn't love a good
fight I don't care if you're an
adrenaline junkie or a tree loving
hippie there's something cathartic about
seeing two or more people beat the
ever-loving [ __ ] out of each other on
screen and anime has produced some
pretty great fights in its history so
with the plethora and huge variety of
anime flights out there I'm sure it's
pretty easy to find decent videos
covering Adam II flights on Utah hey
look it's another top 10 anime fights on
YouTube my favorite [ __ ] kind of
content Wow I wonder what kind of
insight and effort goes into making one
of these videos oh man this video
[ __ ] Sun spice this up a little bit
and he just a little add that here
that's more like it now just go add some
effects oh yeah yeah this is this is so
much better so here's what I'm gonna do
today I want to highlight a number of
great fights in anime that have stood
out to me over the years this isn't a
top list or even necessarily the best
fights in anime but sees that highlight
one really great thing that anime can do
in fight scenes and breaking down what
really makes him stand out from other
fights I liked the part where the guy
hits the other guy in the face but I
know doing a video about anime fights on
YouTube will attract a vocal teenage
demographic wondering why I haven't put
edgy Crito 5 to 7 9 anywhere on here so
I'll do my best to make sure that this
video is as least
edgy as possible
let's start things off with a purist
combat there can be just a good old
fistfight two people going at it with
nothing but the tools they were given by
God
and there have been plenty of great
examples of that in anime the first
fighting taboo tattoo was pretty decent
makishima against Koga means Psychopaths
and hell even the monogatari series had
some good ones in them but if we're
talking the best directed choreographed
and smoothly animated fistfight I still
can't think of a better example than
spike versus Vincent and Cowboy Bebop
the movie specifically both the train
scene and the entire fight this is the
work of legendary animator Yutaka
Nakamura and gear use of their name cuz
you're gonna be hearing a lot of this
video that showcases in my opinion the
best animated fistfight completely
grounded in reality oh there goes
gravity oh there goes sorry what makes
these fights so great is a combination
of brilliant choreographer eke direction
and choice of location with the train
scene in particular being a very
interesting place for a fight as a space
so tight you can see the compact
movement being emphasized as they make
use of what little space there is around
them to gain the upper hand it's a far
cry of what I like to call the Dragon
Ball Z location change where you have
two combatants about to fight being like
look I'm angry and I really want to
punch you in a [ __ ] face but first go
to some really big desolate open fir
that's probably really hard to find
blood Lee's just in my backyard yeah and
let's talk about the choreography
Spike's fighting style is supposed to be
based on Bruce Lee's Jeet Kune oh and he
can totally feel it in the choreography
from the way he bounces mimicking the
legend himself two spikes fluid
movements and combos that Lee was so
famous emphasized over Vincent's rougher
and more rugged fighting style all it's
missing is Lee's signature noses and you
have yourself his next unreleased
masterpiece the way these scenes are
shot also highly resemble the way
live-action martial art scenes are shot
in Asia with minimal camera movement as
opposed to the close-up shaky camp which
only complements the choreography and
overall makes it feel more like you're
watching a Hong Kong action flick than
you are an animated fight which is why I
can't think of a better example of hand
hand combat in anime aside from this one
yeah all right realism is great and all
but sometimes you just want to see some
over-the-top boss sort of all spectacle
of laser beams that can destroy planets
flights that surpass the speed of light
and people getting thrown through twenty
buildings with nothing more than a minor
concussion there's a place for that
it's definitely anime and I'm sure our
first exposure to this was seeing the
fights on Dragon Ball Z but there's so
much more I would never be able to list
them all bleach one piece yuu-yuu
hakusho Fela Kuti Boca new hero JoJo's
iMac or talk about over-the-top fight
scenes without talking of you my shoes
work and kill The Killing gurren lagaan
but the one that Trump's all of these on
pure spectacle alone is Saitama versus
Boris from one punch man now the reason
I chose this fight in particular and the
reason it stands out so much is because
yeah yeah well I apologize that was very
unprofessional of me here on the anime
zone I'm trying to do my best to break
down why these scenes work so well so I
promise I won't get emotionally involved
in the future when analyzing the fights
so as I was saying the one thing that
this fight showcase is better than any
other hold on a second are they playing
the opening song right now i thing this
flight showcases better than any other
flight in anime I've seen is this fun
it's been possible and not to watch this
entire fight without a massive smile on
your face because unlike with other epic
clashes you don't really feel any real
sense of threat at all there is never
any doubt that Saitama is gonna win
since even though he seems a bit more
serious than usual the scene never
portrays him like he's in any immediate
danger
I mean he's [ __ ] moonwalk he is way
into the action for God's sakes normally
this lack of urgency would kill a fight
scene but all of saitama's fights
especially this one manages to capture
spectacle so incredibly well and shows
us that sometimes it's okay to just have
fun and marvel at these spectacular
events happening on screen as a fire
plays out it keeps one-upping itself to
stupid proportions for point west my
time it gets blasted to the [ __ ] moon
and he's like yeah okay you know I guess
I'm on the [ __ ] moon and you can't
help but get sucked in even if you know
that everything that's happening is
absolutely ridiculous and that's the
charm of it
similar to scenes like the final fight
in Kung Fu Hustle we get so caught up
with the ridiculous nature that we just
end up cheering along with this but even
Kung Fu Hustle never manages to reach
the intensity that this fight does
thanks to the spectacular animation
portraying the absolute power and force
of the fight for which you can thank
animate just like our fu me MI and you
taka Nakamura again as opposed to the
bebop fight which was so impressive
because it felt like live-action aspect
to call like this only works so well
because it's animated as everything is
drawn in helps maintain our suspension
of disbelief when something stupid
happens like you know a guy getting
kicked so hard he flies to the [ __ ]
moon but the animation also helps add to
the intensity of it the trailing lights
to imply the speeds that they are moving
the exaggerated movements on every
impact the particle effects all these
techniques help increase the power of
everything happening on screen while
still making the action easy to follow I
mean just look at this one kick and tell
me the same amount of intensity can be
achieved anywhere else
by comparison similar live action
sequences look kind of tame or laughably
silly there's nothing about this fight
that isn't incredibly fun no matter how
many times I watch it so if you want to
sum up everything I just said it
basically just boils down to ah of
course any good fights are great
spectacles and all but they can be so
much more than that actions can speak
louder than words and the fight is no
different a lot of the time the story
behind the punches it's more important
than the punches themselves and the
fights are really stick with us are the
ones where we are invested in the
emotions and story of what's happening
on screen if we're talking fights that
tell a great story I can think of guns
first epic standoff with ahsoka Gohan's
iconic fight with cell and pretty much
every final showdown in one piece is so
chocked full of emotion that it makes
every fight great and memorable even if
they can be pretty average from a
technical standpoint but honestly one of
the best examples I've ever seen of this
comes from the route oh and Sasuke is
final bout in Naruto Shippuden whoa are
you being serious here and a Russo fight
and a ship it and one no less what are
we 13 again Giga all right just stick
with me here yes I know we all stopped
watching the Rito years ago so hands up
who missed this fight that starts in
Episode four seven six Oh what do you
mean he was only episode four seven six
I almost made it that far I can easily
get you up alright I don't blame you for
missing his flight but what makes this
flight so great isn't the spectacle of
it all like previous Naruto fights have
been famous for but for the story that
it tells some pretty good direction I
have some pretty good cinematography and
yes those really were some words you
heard me say about on Naruto fight so
even though I know many of us were in
the root of fans at one point let me
fill in the details you need to know
Naruto follows the story of one
loudmouth Blonsky r21 daydreams of being
the president of the United States even
though for his entire life
everyone's been like dude are you
[ __ ] stupid there's no way you can be
President becomes rival and best friend
with this kid who spends his spare time
shopping at hot
while listening to linkin park who's
also not happy with the country so he's
like yeah I'm gonna go join Isis now
even though the rooters like no don't go
join Isis they're evil and that's
against fun enjoy fast forward a few
years and every toe is in the running to
be President but Sasuke comes back from
trying to blow up the White House and is
like actually I'm gonna be President now
so I can change the country and the
route is like are you an actual idiot
who are [ __ ] international terrorism
[ __ ] and the twist this entire time is
that Naruto was Donald Trump no that's
not really true but the whole point is
that this flight is the story between
two close friends fighting what they
truly believe in it's no huge epic fight
to save the world but it's a clash of
ideology between two people who refuse
to give up and everything about this
fight is packed full of the story
between these characters the way that
the flight starts off with a complete
lack of any music helps to emphasize a
subtle detail that was going on with
every blow from the run up the show's
the two of them through the ages to the
way that you use each other to finish
off their hand signs and even seeing
Sasuke trying to stop Naruto from making
a shadow clone hand sign shows that the
characters have a deep understanding of
each other's fighting style because
everyone knows by now that Naruto's
problem-solving skills basically boil
down to spamming shadow clones enough
time until something happens what's this
people protesting because they're
unhappy with the election results if you
make me shadow cause we've solved the
problem I through all the flashy powers
have been used up those my favorite part
is when the fights divulges into this
brutal fistfight which again happens
without any musics just emphasize the
brutality of these two dudes just
beating the [ __ ] out of each other
culminating in this brilliant minute and
a half long shot of two exhausted and
physically broken guys completely
unwavering in their spirit carry on
fighting for they believed in it's one
of the best directed sequences in this
whole franchise and everything about
this segment uses with the characters
emotion without saying a single word I
like to spend an entire video breaking
down every subtle detail this fight that
tells us something different but since
we're running our time for this segment
I'll just end it with one of the finest
final clashes in anime capping off over
10 years 700 chapters 500 episodes and
two series worth of emotion in a single
blow
and with that I think now would be a
good opportunity to talk about the
sponsor for this episode
Naruto online the game it's a game about
Naruto that's online what that's also
free to play playthrough the original
Naruto storyline and relive your
favorite moments from the original anime
like beating up helpless children haha
take that you dumb ten-year-old the root
are running literally everywhere and
watching Sakura be a useless git oh god
just do something already meet other
players online and even team up with
them hey you want a new route to run
weary oh yeah sure no seriously so this
is the only officially licensed in the
route Oh game online and it shows you
may just be a browser game that's free
to play a lot of Polish has been put
into the look and feel to make it feel
like you're part of the original anime
and the battle system was actually
pretty fun since you can see how well
done the animations are I had fun
partially reliving parts of my childhood
through this cuz we all know Naruto was
the anime that got me into anime so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
have any interest in the route oh if you
do play this game though promise me you
won't have Sacre on your team don't do
it don't do it now going back to fights
so from the outsider perspective it may
sometimes look like fighting boils down
to two miners plebs throwing punches at
each other until one of them connects
because that's certainly what world star
has taught us for anything shot for the
vertical camera but we often times
forget one of the most important tools
used in the fight the brain and smarter
fights are not something completely
unknown to anime Joseph Joestar fights
were equally part stupidly entertaining
as they were smart darker than black had
some interesting use of abilities and
hunter hunter had a great power mechanic
that emphasized strategy and knowledge
over just being the hardest puncher if
you're looking for a battle of the mind
though what I want to talk about is
saber and Lance's first duel than
fate/zero
now the faint franchise is full of
strategic battles both before and during
fights and while this fight may not be
the best Bates call that fate has to
offer I think it does the best in
showing us what goes through a fighter's
mind and even the simplest of Jule's not
to say doesn't look pretty because by
God your food will just get me in bed
already but it does really well to
portray that there are two clear battles
going on in the scene the physical
battle where they are trading blows and
the mental battle where they are trying
to suss out how to gain the upper hand
before even attempted to land a hit it
properly brings you into the mind of a
fighter and while there is a lot of
dialogue everything they think about
feels logical it's not overly
complicated anime monologue for the
simplest action right alright so here's
the plan okay so I'm gonna do is I'm
with her a left hook he's gonna dodge
that I'm gonna go try to help kick him
you'll punch me and we try roundhouse
kick he's gonna back this me and then
after down what I love is that it
highlights how strategy doesn't have to
be some Death Note style use of your
power but even the simplest of details
can be the difference between winning
and losing a jewel and a high-level
battle like this is based around what
information you can gather about your
opponent or lack thereof if you look at
martial artists or professional fighters
like Conor McGregor nobody steps into
the ring without a game plan and no
punches are ever thrown randomly every
move has a purpose whether it be finding
out information about your opponent's or
getting your opponent to move in the way
you want them to and in this battle we
see both sides playing this game say by
trying to figure out what Lancer Spears
can do Lancer misdirecting Sabre into
thinking only one spear matters removing
the armor when it's shown is ineffective
being cautious of the length of the
invisible sword and in the end it's the
simplest of faints that loss Sabre into
a trap which you probably would have
fallen for if not for all the subtle
information Lancer had previously given
her it's great because while simple the
strategy is incredibly deep and I love
that we are left to draw this conclusion
ourselves rather than some third party
character telling us oh my god skill
these people are we don't need a third
party monologue telling us that these
are two really high-level fighters as
they are essentially playing the fastest
real-time game of yugioh in their minds
complete with magic and trap cards and
everyone watching here actually
understanding what's going on and it was
wonderful to see how this fight played
out in the fighter's minds as much as it
was to see what was happening on-screen
this was a jewel in the truest sense and
one of my favorite fights that involved
more than just smacking another dude in
the face really [ __ ] hard I'm
fantasm even be merely a single weapon a
trap of course I'd be remiss if I made a
5 video and didn't mention the 1i
chronic weapon imprinted on Japanese
culture the samurai sword yes ask any
commoner what they think Japan is famous
for and that probably answers something
along lines of weird TV electronics
something something tentacle porn and of
course the samurai so it should come as
no surprise that there have been plenty
of great sword fights in anime history
from the classic ones like Ninja Scroll
and Rhoni Kenshin to the new ones like
Afro Samurai and of course the famous
samurai Champloo sponsored by her
blessin sirs but if we're going to talk
about breathtaking sword fights the only
spot this was ever gonna go to is
no-name vs. Liu Lang's final showdown in
sort of the stranger so what happens if
you take always everything we talked
about previously and put it into one
fight well this happens the finale is
sort of the stranger manages to showcase
everything that can be great about an
anime fight in a single scene and it
does it beautifully it does this by
taking cues from old samurai movies from
the classic slow build-up and standoff
before a fight to the flashy exchanges
of blows and the brief pauses between
sword clashes of course the choreography
is excellent and the animation is
absolutely stunning which is thanks to
oh hey look a sign name i've never seen
before here let me so I can take a bit
more and a fantastic cinematography and
music also helps to frame this as an
epic duel but what really elevators
fight above all others is how dynamic it
feels there is nothing about this jewel
that is static and I've never seen
another fight in anime that makes such
fantastic use of the environment around
them taking the basics of what we
learned from the Cowboy Bebop train
fight the scene takes it up a notch as
the environment they are fighting in is
constantly changing and not only that
but it becomes an active component of
the fight you can see how they try to
use it to gain every little advantage
they can the way they corner each other
on the ledge brushing snow in their
faces and whenever they move around or
change location it isn't unintended but
it's done in service of trying to win
the fight itself the more you watch it
the more you realize that there is no
movement that is unplanned or
unnecessary sure or the swordplay is
flashy and everything but there's a
deeper sense of awareness for both
fighters going on regarding their
surroundings and then manages to convey
this higher level of strategy like what
we talked about in fade zero without
uttering a single word all these
elements blend together resulting in
arguably the best anime
fight in history so just take my word
for it and watch this fight you don't
even need to watch the rest of the film
even though there are some great fights
in it throughout well this is the one
fights in anime that deserves to be
watched and marbled that
and that was all I had time to cover
today I hardly even scratch the surface
of why I could cover though so who knows
I probably have to make another one of
these in the future because there are so
many animate flights I could talk about
thanks to my good friend I know for
helping you research this video he also
did a good video breaking down what
makes a good anime flight too so if you
want further information I highly
recommend you check out that video don't
worry Jimmy that's a free plug on me and
again a huge thanks to Naruto online for
sponsoring this video and just letting
me talk about anime fights cuz I can do
that all [ __ ] day if you do have any
interests in the retail - I do think
you'll enjoy this game so just give it a
shot if you want but now I do look
forward to reading all your insightful
comments about everything I said oh my
god I can't believe you didn't mention
my favorite fight you know Trump versus
Hillary versus Cory in the House vs.
Harambee your casual Club